[Music]
non-alcoholic beers almost
unrecognizable from a few years ago
what's made it such a hit
[Music]
it was once a watery pretty tasteless
beverage that you drank not because you
wanted to but because there wasn't much
choice
well that all started to change about
five years ago
Heineken introduced a product called 0.0
and that sort of changed the game they
made it really groovy they started
sponsoring events like formula one and
all of a sudden the category became a
lot more flavorful and a lot more
interesting
Brewers are getting better at making
non-alcoholic beers so that it used to
be a non-alcoholic beer was really a
pretty poor option
um and you know you sort of maybe you
did it to feel like you were hanging out
and look like you have a beer in your
hand but the actual enjoyment Factor was
pretty low
today it's experiencing tremendous
growth the global non-alcoholic beer
market was estimated to be worth around
16.6 billion dollars in 2021 and it's
forecast to reach over 23 billion in
2025 smaller companies including craft
breweries are also vying for a piece of
the market we like to think athletic
really got the ball rolling in this
space not alcohol crappier has been the
fastest growing category in beer for
four plus years now with athletic being
a 53 chair player of that category
driving over 60 percent of growth this
year and there's over 40 other breweries
in this category now it's not a just a
couple Brands doing this anymore
athletic Brewing Company recently opened
what is believed to be the largest
dedicated non-alcoholic Brewery in the
world
[Music]
we celebrate with anytime anywhere
whether or not you want alcohol and it
still tastes just as good if not better
than your usual beer just makes people
choose it more often than not and so
they get to enjoy their beer and be at
their best
eighty percent of our our drinkers do
drink alcohol at other occasions so the
trend of like they called zebra striping
where people drink alcohol not alcohol
alcohol not alcohol throughout a night
to Pace out their session moderate their
ABV intake has become increasingly
common and in some New York City bars
we've been the top selling beer period
on their whole menu for over a year run
athletic Brewing Company really is
leading the game I asked them about it
and they said there was a place called
top hops in downtown Manhattan where
they have consistently been the
best-selling beer it's an exciting sign
and it's also a sign of just how much
attitudes have changed
while there used to be stigmas attached
to not drinking that has really changed
dramatically in the last four or five
years gen Z and the younger generation
is choosing not to drink for health
reasons they won't be shamed about it
and they're Unapologetic about it
not drinking sometimes can feel like
you're doing something unusual just
because in society most people drink so
having these non-alcoholic options lets
me do what I used to do but without
having to drink along the way
this current boom and not alcoholic beer
is really part of the sort of General
lifestyle awareness of better balance
better balance and everything better
balance with work better balance in life
and also the realization that you don't
always have to have alcohol to have fun
non-alcoholic beer is still finding its
footing in the U.S we've come a long way
it was 0.3 percent of the beer category
we started it's 1.5 percent of all
grocery sales now in the beer category
we're getting there we just need better
distribution better marketing awareness
to keep building those numbers
there's no question that non-alcoholic
beer market is going to continue to grow
in parts of Europe it's five to ten
percent of the market I don't see any
reason why it can't be the same here in
the United States
[Music]